it's been two weeks since this whole
thing started it all started with a
tearing car accident it was all over the
news everyone thought it was just
another oil spill were plenty of
volunteers plenty of people wanting to
help the poor defenseless animals plenty
of victims within hours of the tanker
accident it started happening the
animals had gone crazy
they were scratching biting the cleanup
volunteers they said it was a adverse
effect of whatever was in that tanker
rescue workers were still trying to get
the crew out of the ship and they could
hear screaming inside screams to open
the doors that's when it all went to
hell as soon as they cut the door out
there was six minutes of broadcast
before it went silent six minutes of
screaming and agony the ship crew
attacked the rescue workers like rabid
baboons breaking bones tearing flesh the
people on the shore weren't faring any
better those that have been attacked by
the animals were attacking everyone else
it was worse than any boars own report
it was sheer brutality and yet the
broadcast still went on for six minutes
six minutes and then the blank faces
nobody could explain what was happening
they tried to continue with regular news
the economy the weather acute human
interest story but they couldn't make us
unsee what we saw I tried to continue
with my regular existence but every time
I switched on the news or walked by a
newsstand it was there this big mystery
they had some explanations some kind of
infection brain parasites but it didn't
matter
it wasn't an infection we were afraid of
it was them four days after the initial
report the state of emergency was raised
and yet we'd all seen this before if
every zombie movie ever people didn't
know who to trust people were
stockpiling food and weapons some tried
to flee but it seems every zombie movie
was right they didn't make it three days
later they arrived in my town I expected
moans shuffling corpses dismemberment
but that's where the movies lied they
ran through the streets screaming I
remember running to my front door as
fast as I could
locking barricading it's doing anything
to make sure it would stay shut and then
I headed for the window I was on the
second storey and I could see the
carnage they were unstoppable they were
aware a group of them made their way
through a building across the street
they jumps straight through plate glass
windows even the shards slicing through
the make no difference they just kept
coming
my barricade wasn't gonna hold I rushed
around my flat
grabbing supplies and jamming them into
the most secure room in the flat I went
back for one last look across the street
where I wish I had in a second-story
window my face met with one of theirs
they knew where I was I quickly dashed
into the room unlocked the door I don't
have any kind of panic room or a secure
basement
so the safest place I could think of was
my bathroom no windows one door with a
lock I filled my sink and bathtub full
of water so I could stay for a while so
I sat there in the dark room with a
distance screams in my ears I began to
feel like I may have overreacted
it had been two hours and no sign of him
it actually got quieter
I thought they'd moved on maybe I could
leave the room get to the kitchen grab
or food to wait it out a crash came from
the front door the sound of someone
running full force into the door and
knocking down the barrier behind it
there was a couple more crash
before I knew they were inside rapid
footsteps moving around the flat a
couple screams and then a bang on the
wall beside me my eyes were open to the
widest even in the pitch-black darkness
of the room another bang and another
they knew I was there and they knew I
was scared
this was the zombie nightmare I've been
expecting from a start I had nowhere to
run there was only so much time before
they would break in i sat with my back
to the door hoping my extra weight would
make it harder for them to get in and
then it got worse a voice on the
opposite side of the door
no screams or moans just a quiet
whispery voice and then more of them the
whispery voices became a cacophony of
noise trying to persuade me to break me
the fool me I'd heard that the moaning
of zombies would drive people insane
this was worse a siren call I seven the
darkness and hoped and prayed that they
get bored but they don't get bored and
they don't leave I managed to use the
mirror to peek under the door only to be
greeted by horrible unblinking eyes
bloody smeared faces screams and more
horrible mispers that was two days ago I
don't know what to do anymore
maybe it won't be so bad